foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
but I feel her
I hear her heartbeat
[Music]
she's so close
[Music]
so what does her heartbeat sound like
[Music]
mighty
foreign
[Music]
before your birth
and after your death
with me
and I need you to be strong
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Christmas
one Dark Soul is selected for Redemption
by the ghosts of Christmas past present
and yet to come the tradition that
continues to this very nice
Like A Christmas Carol yes yes if you
would just let me get this outfit so out
of all the people on the planet
murderers people who do gender reveal
parties I'm the guy you're gonna hug you
know what forget it
foreign
I can take this guy I'm your Ghost of
Christmas present
I'm not watching your dramatic
re-encrapment hey I'm haunting you you
can't just run away from me when I'm
haunting you hello
I believe he can be a positive force for
mankind and he's got his hands all over
everything yeah I wish come on are you
texting HR no
people don't sing We got a runner
that's just fun to watch
I'm here to change into being a more
positive force for Humanity yeah
you photoshop yourself into these
pictures of my executive VP I don't
think so oh you want that what I want is
for you to shut up and let me do my job
is there a Ghost of Christmas grumpy
because you could do that job
[Music]
where real change begins
Oh that's oh he's dead yeah he's
definitely no no he's fine he's good wow
anyway
[Music]
[Music]
I just saw on the calendar that right
now on Earth it's almost Christmas time
we don't have time for trivialities like
Christmas but Peter's so sad about
Gamora being gone
we go to Earth they're a really
wonderful Christmas gift
[Music]
something special you will never forget
what about someone special
we are looking for the legendary Kevin
Bacon we're looking for the legendary
Kevin Bacon your voice is smaller I
think maybe he didn't hear you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
Captain Torrance flight Commander how
can I help you fugitive extradition
[Music]
oh is he dangerous what did he do
homicide 15 years ago I don't want to
scare the rest of the passengers I'm
afraid you're stuck with this Captain
get him on board let's have a good
flight
I'll come right through the top of the
storm
let's keep everybody in their seats no
exceptions all right
we are dark
then went down somewhere in the Jolo
Island cluster
it's run by separatists and militias the
Filipino Army won't even go there
anymore
the clock is ticking every minute
matters
we can count those minutes in lives lost
or saved
an emergency I'm captain Brody Torrance
I like this guy
Maxwell Carver England
right passengers my responsibility
I need your help you're gonna need this
former militarism you can see that
the wife to lock you up no one cares
what really happened but they say
redemption can be found in the most
unusual places
you'll probably never see your family
again what about their families
I have a daughter and I have every
intention of making a home
they are going to come at us with
everything they've got
we're getting off this island
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
I used to ask myself a lot of questions
Scott you're at ex-con
how are you an Avenger that doesn't make
sense
but everywhere I go people tell me the
same thing thank you Spiderman
people still need help Dad that's why we
made this
like a satellite for deep space but
Quanah wait wait a minute you're sending
a signal down to the quantum Realm
turn it off
now
[Music]
oh
[Music]
where
are we
going tonight
[Music]
it's a secret Universe beneath ours
what are you so afraid of
there's something I never told you
[Music]
it isn't what you think
[Music]
[Music]
I can get you home
and give you more time
if you help me
so
What's it gonna be
Ant-Man
[Music]
Egypt a land of mystery intriguing and
Rich history
doorway episodes to afterlife a world of
mummies under the Earth
[Music]
a royal wedding ring
it's the man the man took the ring the
only way to get it back is to go to the
world of the living
[Music]
[Music]
wow
it's beautiful
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that's enough I come to bring you home
son
I feel the undertale
we were involved in 93 000 deaths last
year
they keep piling up one after another
hey Mike how's it going it was brown I
suppose like the world or like a toilet
difference of perspective I reckon
over that's what you're asking me right
now
[Music]
welcome to the family
[Music]
I love you ruby red
Ruby hey hey come on wake up oh Ruby oh
no Ruby
she wanted to be washed in the river
okay Ruby had choices but some of them
choices were made for
him
I want you to feel what she felt when
she died
Shelley John suspected in the killing of
a local heroin dealer
if you find him tell him I just want to
talk
can I help you
[Music]
if you left your lab you must have told
him something what was it I ain't seen
who do you work for
you think God improves what you've been
doing
if that wasn't god pushing me to do his
business I don't know what it was
[Music]
I still got something left there
I spent the last seven years of my life
living out my wildest dreams
Bianca
Rocky
my dad
spilled on their shoulders
hey my man can I help you let me get
autograph no I ain't signing the
autographs but get off my car y'all
remember me huh
[Music]
Damien
how long were you locked up 18 Years bro
just got out last week
because I know you back up I know I've
been away a long time but myself in
shape I still got gas in the tank come
by the gym
thank you
[Music]
girls what happened with you too oh you
can tell you he was like brothers
I was the best though but I never got a
chance to prove that that's cute
I know what you doing Donnie you don't
always do nothing
Damien's fighting the world he's trying
to hurt people I bounce for you you
think you mad try spending half your
life in the cell why did somebody else
live your life
I'm coming for everything you
threatening me
something is going on with you Amy was
like family
[Music]
oh we passed talking then maybe you just
have to find out
these are family times I recognize mine
I know that they needed me
yet I ain't scared me yet
I need you to make all your fear
they're called a guilt
let go of whatever was and walk into
what it is
[Music]
the world has changed
[Music]
I want the world to never forget money
I will need thank you
senior farad in my opinion you're making
the best cars in the world
but with all my Ferraris that is a
problem the clutch I have a solution if
you consider a partnership Ferrari
Lamborghini go back to your tractors
farmer
what are you thinking
that doesn't exist yet one that is a
strong and powerful and is Unforgettable
as the board
go to build it
how long will it take can't be done if
it doesn't work we'll lose everything
you want me to be like everyone else
it's not impossible until we fail in six
months in Geneva people will be looking
for the next fat eyes
and what they will find is the first
level
[Applause]
something new I don't know if this would
work
[Music]
we'll be ready for this one day
tell me why you think that the world
needs another luxury car it's Perfection
that I am after
don't care about me the only thing that
matters is a great Lamborghini what do
you want me to do
to make the best cars
responsibility to tell them what you're
doing
[Music]
let's go go
Lamborghini is too uneducated to
understand what he doesn't know
you buy a Ferrari when you want to be
someone
you buy a Lamborghini when you are
someone
[Music]
what do you see lines on a napkin what
do you see
I know that change can be scary but it
can also be exciting
[Applause]
let's start our new life
[Music]
does anyone in Andalusia ever just say
stuff not if we can help it
this world feels very different is it
sometimes easier to live in andalasia
well I wouldn't say easier we have
dragons and ogre rebellions last year
the entire kingdom was trapped in a
giant whale oh this is not a magic land
it is a land far far away from my
friends I'm so lit I'm a commuter now
you're riding this train over and over
and over and over and over and over and
over and then you die
as you can see Giselle everyone has
their place once you've found where you
fit Monroeville can be
whatever you wish I wish for a Fairytale
life
happily ever after it's not always that
easy
like dresses
Jumping Jelly sticks we got magic
town is turning into a fairy tale
but it's all gone terribly wrong on the
last stroke of midnight
be as it was before
not an evil cat I'm not an evil cat I'm
not an evil cat what is going on you
need to remember your place here Mr
mother please
[Music]
is it under a curse we have to stop this
or everything and Elation will die
there's no one wishing your wish now
Giselle come on time to be heroes you
know there's only one villain in this
town
you're hilarious
delusional but hilarious
foreign
super fun
um
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
are you if you're a little but the
ranger to my sword
this is my fourth year in the center how
about you I started the whole damn thing
[Music]
we decided that you could have one gift
early
what is it that is a direct hotline of
Santa Claus himself I can talk to Santa
all right revelers welcome to your worst
Christmas shopping let's go
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
Debbie said you were very busy tonight
[Music]
are you gonna help us
no my nice list
of time for some Seasons beatings
who the hell are you
but what if he really is the real no
such thing as Santa
that's naughty
and what do you do to the naughty ones I
give my life a call
where is it I gotta watch
I believe in you Santa
which one of you did that Prancer
so unprofessional
[Music]
fellow life moves fast one day you're
playing Kick the Can with kids named
flick and Schwartz
the next thing you know you're a
certified adult
Ralph dear old man
he was the best
promise me we're gonna make this a
wonderful Christmas that would make your
father so happy I promise
what have I done and that was all up to
me I suggest you start drinking and
don't stop till New Year's
the kids who wants to go see Santa what
is this amazing incredible we will meet
you right here when you're done don't
let him kick you in the face
decorating it kind of feels like child
labor honey it's not labor if we don't
pay you yeah
cheers
that doesn't mean it was easy
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
surface world
oh my God we know what you whisper
is
show them
cool we are
[Music]
[Music]
I just never thought I would come back
here
you don't got love for this city
it's not the city
sad house
I'm the only one that made it out
[Music]
I got a drop you didn't work cleaning
pools what are you doing bullets
I'm cleaning them
hey look if it get dark now you just you
just ride it okay yeah yeah
how do I do that
I uh what's up
I work for the Army Corps of Engineers
now I need him to clear me so I can go
back you got blown up over there you
want to go back
what happened those are the car accident
on the causeway
I'm kind of on a lot of medication got a
medication like don't shoot yourself in
the head kind of medication okay
I got to get away
you go back yes
should you go back it's a different
question
how cool business going
it's cutthroat
no
[Music]
what are you doing here Nicholas hasn't
been to school in almost a month
I wanted to ask how are you has
something happened you realize the
school is talking about expelling you
can I live with you
you said you don't feel very close to
people your age
your other son he needs you as well
and you're at work all of the time
they're talking about the divorce
I've tried to be there for you I've
tried to give you strength what's going
on are you on drugs you think you can
just live your life doing whatever you
feel like
I don't know what's happening to me
I feel like a complete failure
I wasn't there fan
there used to be so much joy in our
family we give these big speeches about
life and then you abandoned us I have
the right to reinvent my life
thank you hello so you came to tell me
what a good dad you are what do you want
Applause
that's my little boy I can't give up on
it
[Music]
did you get on a dating up finally Jesus
stop living in denial denial of what
dick you live in a dick denial
Nina broke up and now they're over there
trying to see who gets to stay in
regular here we have people write down
challenges and whoever wins gets to stay
okay I'm an attorney I fight for a
living bring it
[Applause]
[Music]
human bowling nice choice oh
that's what you get
you need to kill anyone
the Mary Poppins from hell
[Applause]
[Music]
he's catching up over here from toss it
back trust me I was in a sorority I put
things in my throat all the time
[Music]
all right all right well I gotta say
that is a very handsome client why
didn't you step me up with him you
deserve someone nice
[Music]
Cherie Ethan
that's me
[Music]
I thought you would appreciate the best
sushi in L.A
[Music]
one drink
the only thing that matters now is our
game
through the night
[Music]
you are a marked woman now
she can smell you
[Music]
if you want to survive his game
I just need to lay low tonight
how are you surviving now huh
no one beats him he's like a monster
what are you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
would be a chance to reconnect
I see now that maybe we were never
really connected
wow that's real shame on it
oh my God have you seen this invitation
are you going to the wedding Eloise is
our half sister which means we can half
past the relationship
my rich sister chose to stay in London
and shove fish and chips up her butt
that's not how you eat them
my company upgraded me very cool country
mouse I figured that everyone in
business class was going to be hot and
mean like you they got Paddington on
this flight
stink
[Music]
this is the worst thank you for coming
to England my nuptials she's like
netaporte and I'm like Nordstrom Rack
Alice the wine dispelling you bet it is
Mom she sounds like a monster so lovely
having you all here only 72 hours until
the big guy too
oh God Alice I'm fine I think I just had
some bad chicken I had me chicken
it's wonderful being here with my
children and all their friends you know
he's not my friend you know I support
you excuse me if sir yes he's my son
what's happening and they do sex things
it's a-okay with me and I'm proud
I'm getting married
from this moment forward you will behave
like a normal family who is here to
happily celebrate a loved one's wedding
is that understood she's even prettier
when she's angry absolutely radiant
[Music]
all right
do you think this is funny I do you know
how at every wedding there are those
people everyone talk about after cousin
Randy oh we're those people at this time
oh Savage mom
[Applause]
[Music]
hey Square I am not a square I think we
should invite Greg this weekend what's
this weekend
these people are hippies Rebels against
old-fashioned Authority I think these
kids need help the need is a bear you're
passing judgment on people you know
nothing about maybe that's why your
church is so empty when God walks in
here brings me a hippie I'll ask him
what it's all about because I do not
understand
his house has a very good vibe
[Applause]
[Music]
there is an entire generation
just in all the wrong places if you want
to reach my people you need to speak to
them in a language they understand if I
bring them in a little does my job I can
only walk through doors open to us in
your church that's a door that shut
you've probably noticed we have some
guests here today I'd like you to meet
my new friends welcome
they don't belong here half of the
morning wearing shoes they're staying in
the new shag carpet they need our help
if you feel like you're misunderstood
and judged you will find forgiveness and
freedom right here that was awesome now
that door is open any time of day and if
there are some who don't like that well
then that door works both ways all right
Pastor let's begin I was almost done
with this but then you did what nobody
else would even dared
thing that we found I feel like I belong
you're gonna need a bigger Church
country is a dark and divided place but
now there's hope and it's spreading this
is your home and I want you to tell all
your friends about it
[Music]
that's what priests
[Music]
I'm Gino Park a detective from Seoul
police station would you be able to come
to the Institute good thing she might be
Chinese some come to get a job and send
money to their families in China life is
tough for them and they're all alone the
organ removal was done right by a
surgeon Oregon trafficing do you have a
child no yeah
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you